create a meeme that Xbox has no
exclusive game pushing wider audiences
away number three be confused why
everyone thinks this is a bad ideal
number four pivot when it's too
late continue s there you go it's like
it's by not saying it anything about it
right um it's you're kind of stepping on
a rake that you don't have to that's
what's up but at the end of the day if
it's not true at if it's not true then
it was all for nothing everybody's
helping and puing it's not true talk he
G
oh 100% happen inch it just sucks that
these dudes got to always validate their
relationship with these suckers every
day yeah we're still married
honey honey we're still married